These are the type of dragons from myths and legends across Asia.
In contrast to their Western counterparts,...
...these dragons are not known to eat people or attack a castle...
...or chase a bunch of dwarves out of their homes for their gold.
In Western culture, the dragons represent evil and darkness.
Unlike the celestial images of the Eastern dragon,...
...the Western dragon has sharp teeth and strong legs.
It is said to bring harm, suffering, and fear to humankind.
In China, as well as in most places in Asia, the dragon or "long",...
...as said in Chinese, is commonly the symbol of nobility, solemness, holiness, and good fortune.
Throughout the history of China, Korea, and Japan,...
...the dragon, or the concept of the dragon, has been a part of people's daily lives.
The dragon has existed wherever Chinese culture existed.
And the Chinese eventually began calling themselves the descendants of the dragon.